not to bring up another controversy but
we're talking about all this
have you discussed how you're going to
raise the baby
you know because i when dad and i since
we're different faiths
my grandmother and my mother wanted
aaron to be baptized
and we had promised his father and
mother that she would
be go to hebrew school and learn the
jewish religion and i had a lot of
trouble with that because i wanted
her to be baptized where happy
the babies baptized i didn't tell them
yet so
i was about to tell them what's what are
you telling us
i agree baby asked and he said the one
thing that he really wants is really
important and really important to your
family
is that we baptize the baby
[Music]
so i justified it to myself you're just
gonna put him in some water
and you know it's nice everyone's gonna
have a party for him
you know so i just don't want to analyze
it too much
because of what it really means
when you baptize them they're baptized
into that faith usually
being told that abby is going to be
baptized
is a true shock but i thought having
spoken to harry
that abby would be brought up jewish
i think it's i think he's being forced
upon he certainly would not
have come from her
i think you know i don't shock very
easily
but um this is this is getting up there
baptisms he came to be basically crying
and asked me please this is so important
for me yeah it's very important
and you know what honestly i don't know
if it's that important for you i feel
like it's you guys who really put
pressure on him
this is important this is our religion
he must baptized and also our culture
so i don't know why not you change your
mind for
the baby it is must
i don't think it's a must i'm letting
him do it you don't baptize
yeah the baby goes to heaven
i don't like this idea of hell you go
you're bad you're going to hell
that's really important i don't want
hell in his life
and i told you if i catch you doing that
that would be one of the reasons that i
really would leave
you acts like he's eggs now i swear that
is real that's really
you're gonna let your sisters talk to me
like this